SUZANNE XIE: Our
world has changed
so much since I was a kid that
things that I want to do now
weren't even possible
for me to imagine.
JEANNIE YANG: I
don't even know if I
knew it was called computer
science and programming.
KELLY ELLIS: It all sort
of happened by accident.
BRYNN EVANS: I
was always excited
about technology in
some way, and people.
LIMOR FRIED: I
thought that was just
really neat to be able to
control the technology,
instead of just
having it control you.
ASHLEY GAVIN: I think
a lot of people wake up
and they have an amazing idea.
When you know how to code, you
can go and actually make that
a reality.
SHANNON SPANHAKE: I am the
deputy innovation officer.
BRYNN EVANS: I'm a design lead.
JAY WONG: A UI designer.
CASSANDRA DIXON:
A port engineer.
KELLY ELLIS: Software engineer.
JOANNA SMITH: Developer
programs engineer.
JEANNIE YANG: Chief
product and design officer.
MEGAN SMITH: I'm a VP.
NATALIE GORDON: I'm
the CEO and founder.
HEIDI ZAK SPECTOR: Co-founder.
BANDANA MALIK: I am a coder.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: By learning
about engineering, computer
science, and other
technical skills,
you can solve the
really big problems.
MEGAN SMITH: We're trying to
do things that could radically
improve the world.
JAY WONG: Things like
transportation and health.
BANDANA MALIK: Making our
cities better places to live,
and making people
more connected.
JENNY YOUNG: A place for city
kids to build and create.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: I created a
moon TV system to project video
on the moon.
HEIDI ZAK SPECTOR:
Computer vision technology.
LIMOR FRIED: Open-source
hardware company.
SHANNON SPANHAKE:
Measure air pollution
with your mobile phone.
BRYNN EVANS: I love helping
people do the things
that they love to
do more easily.
AMINATOU SOW: I
really, really, really
enjoy the fact that I get
energy from so many people.
ASHLEY GAVIN: I just hope
that I can see the world
change in my lifetime.
That inspires me.
CASSANDRA DIXON: So build it
around something that you like.
KELLY ELLIS: Find something
that interests you.
MEGAN SMITH: What are
you passionate about?
NATALIE GORDON: Know
what's the thing that's
going to keep you going.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: And
you can really, really
have an impact on the world.
[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
PAVNI DIWANJI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome.
I am Pavni Diwanji.
I'm a VP of
engineering at Google.
And I was so stoked
when Natalie asked
me to introduce this session.
I have been, from a very
early age, very fascinated
with robots.
A lot of my childhood
conversations
were dominated by R2D2 and
C3PO, at home and at school.
There were two factions at
school in the geek crowd,
you know?
There was the R2D2 faction.
And then there was
the C3PO faction.
And we spent endless hours
debating virtues and vices
of those beloved robots, so.
And I have to say, nothing
really has changed.
A few months ago, I was sitting
at my Sunday breakfast family
place and my daughter--
we were eating pancakes.
And my daughter blurted
out very suddenly
that she wished C3
was more like Jarvis.
Now, I kind of know that she's
a Iron Man, Tony Stark fanatic.
But it still kind of
took me by surprise.
Normally, our conversations
are not that interesting.
It's normally about school,
and Minecraft, and Pokemon.
And robots show up
in the conversation.
I'm like, OK, OK.
Take a deep breath.
And I'm like, "Tell me more."
And so-- and then, but
before she could answer,
my younger daughter,
Maya, who's eight,
was not going to be left
out of the conversation.
And she jumped in.
And she says,
"Well, it's obvious
why she likes Jarvis more."
I'm like, why?
"Well, C3 just
doesn't get kids."
I'm like, "Oh, is
that the reason?"
So I'm like mentally getting
prepared to explain to them why
it's such a hard
problem to recognize
different types of
voices and stuff.
But before I get a
chance to actually get
into the conversation, there's
a sibling rivalry going on.
And Ishana, who is a
teenager, gets back
into the conversation.
Like, "That's not it at all.
I really like Jarvis
because it has
a real personality
and an attitude."
So I'm like, OK.
Now we are talking about
robots with a personality
and an attitude.
OK.
So anyway, where this
conversation ended was
my eight-year-old
is like telling me,
like, "I want to build a robot.
And Mommy, I think I can build
a better robot than Jarvis."
And, like parents do,
I'm like letting it pass.
And next day, she's
like relentless, right,
a few days following.
So I'm, like, scratching
my head, what to do.
And so finally, I ended up
getting her a LEGO Mindstorm
Kit.
And here she is!
She built a little rover
robot a few months ago.
And the reason I
tell this story is--
[APPLAUSE]
It's a silly family story.
But I like to tell it,
because I find it fascinating
that robots never cease to
be an interesting topic,
no matter how old you get.
And I remember, at
a very early age,
going through thought exercises
on how to build a C3PO.
And yeah, I was in that faction.
But-- and it was kind of hard.
You have to imagine a
time where I was in India.
There's not that many
resources available.
TV had just arrived.
No internet, no cloud,
no Google, right?
It's kind of hard to imagine
bringing C3PO to life.
But now, the landscape
has changed, right?
We have fast networks.
We have maps.
We know-- we understand
the terrain really well.
We have the cloud.
We have Google, right?
Robots don't have to do it all
alone, if they have the cloud
helpline, as I like to call it.
Oh, I don't know how to
recognize this object.
Let's dial the helpline, right?
I don't know how to-- I don't
quite understand the language.
They can also ask the cloud.
So indeed, it's like a really
different, exciting time.
And a lot has changed.
And I feel like robots
are amongst us already.
It's hard to imagine
a future without them,
whether it's like cuddly
toys we're talking about,
or robots helping
us in emergencies,
or robots helping us with
the car assembly line,
or driving cars for us,
or navigating on Mars.
You know, they are here to stay.
And they're here next to us,
helping us for the future.
So today, I am
super-excited, because you're
going to hear from three awesome
Googlers who have built robots
to assist a person in
need, assist a community,
and assist humanity at large.
And I would like
to invite Yoky, who
is our vice president
of technology at Nest,
to kick off this very
exciting session.
Welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
YOKY MATSUOKA: Hello, everybody.
I'm so happy to be here today.
At Nest, for those of you who
know Nest, as well as those
of you who are getting
introduced today,
we build-- or, we actually
reinvent-- unloved products
in your house, such
as thermostats,
and smoke detector.
And we actually today
launched a developers program.
Yay!
[APPLAUSE]
Plug.
Unplug.
So-- and then, what we--
and one of the things,
actually, we do is that we
build beautiful product that
used to be unloved.
Now, people start to love.
And not only beautiful
to look at, but also
beautiful to interact with.
And the kind of
things that we do
is to really
understand how humans
learn to interact
with certain devices,
and then have machine
learning to interact together.
And this synergy is where we can
make the experience beautiful.
So that's what we're
going to talk about--
except that this
is where I'm going
to stop talking about Nest.
And I'm going to
actually tell you
a little bit about
robotics, and a little bit
of a history of
how I got to Nest.
And, really, I'm going
to talk about enabling
human experience.
And again, this machine
learning and human experience
combination-- really,
what I like to do
is to enable who you want to be.
So just take a
thermostat as an example.
How many people actually
like to save energy?
Almost everybody.
OK, that's great.
So how many people who
are staying at the hotel
and remember to turn off your
air conditioner or heating
right before you
left the room today?
Not enough.
And that's pretty common.
But don't worry.
What we can do
with the technology
through understanding who you
are-- you want to save energy.
But you sometimes forget,
because you're human.
Well, we can [INAUDIBLE]
for that together.
See, this is kind
of the synergisting
that I'm talking about.
So, you want to be
an energy saver?
Great.
We'll enable it.
Well, I actually wanted
to be a tennis player.
So a technology that could
enable me to be a tennis player
would be great.
But, as I grew up
playing tennis,
and I was competing at
an international level,
I started to get injured
all the time in college.
And I have come to
realize that maybe I'm
not going to be the number-one
player in the world.
So, at the point, I
had to reinvent myself,
and said, well, what
am I going to do next?
Well, I know tennis.
How about if I built a little
tennis buddy for myself?
It's made of robots,
has legs and arms,
and then it has
buttons and a tummy.
And then if you push
a certain button,
it might make that robot to
be really, really amazing
and a great person-- I mean,
great robot to play with.
Or another button
that you can press,
which would make it a
little bit weak on the day
that I'm feeling a
little down, and I
want to beat something up.
So that's the kind of
things that I was imagining.
Wouldn't that be great if
I could build something
like this?
So, throughout
college, I started
to do much more of engineering.
And I got involved, and I
even went to grad school
to build a humanoid robot
that looks like this.
This is called Cog.
And I joined a team to
build arms and hands,
and to really try to approach
the human-level cognition
to intelligence, to movement
that we can mimic like humans.
Well, but a couple
of years later,
I realized that it's
really hard to do that
with-- at that
time-- the technology
of artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
And I felt the reason
is because we just
don't understand the human brain
and how it works well enough.
So, I jumped across.
I studied neuroscience
so that, one day,
I was still hoping that I can
build a tennis player that
could play tennis with me.
But throughout this
whole sort of journey
of migrating to neuroscience,
what I've come to learn
is that there are
a lot of people
who have neurological
disorders who could get help
by all the knowledge
that I've already
had in machine learning,
AI, and robotics.
So that's when I started to
think, maybe, just maybe.
What I like to do is to
really help other people.
Somehow sort of reach
out to those people,
using some things
that I already know.
And trying to see
if I can help them
become who they want to be.
So that's pretty
much what I did.
I was a professor
for over a decade,
really trying to invent this
field called neurobiotics,
or you might know, as it a
brain-computer interface,
brain-machine interface.
It's really about taking
some of the brain signals,
and then extracting it, and
technologically speaking.
And then enhance it.
And then put it back on either
a limb that's paralyzed,
or a prosthetic limb for those
people who lost their limbs.
So this is a tool, as well
as a future prosthetic limb
that I built, spending a long
time trying to understand how
humans make such an amazing
motion using their hand.
This is so simple for us.
Yet, for a robot to
just even do this,
this is almost completely
impossible, even today.
So why is that?
Is this a mechanical secret?
Or is this something that
our brain is sending?
So, really dove into
the scientific deep end
of trying to understand how
we can enable those people who
lost their movement.
And through that
research, actually
something-- lots of
nuggets have been found.
And some of the
nuggets have gone
into actual prosthetic devices
that thousands of people
wear now.
This is called Touch
Bionics i-Limb.
So those are really
exciting little nuggets.
But, primarily, I was
really thinking about people
about 30 years down the line.
But it didn't just have to
be about wearable devices.
It could be something that
just sits on the ground.
This is a robot that
sits on the ground.
And then somebody-- this
is a student from Harvard,
but pretending to be a stroke--
somebody who had a stroke.
And sitting and then interacting
with the robotic device safely.
As he's interacting
with it, now the robot
is gathering information
about the person.
The person wants to recover.
The person who had
an injury, and then
maybe have half
the body paralyzed,
can actually try to
start to exercise.
And then the robot
side can understand,
is this person tired?
Is this person
learning right now?
Is this person able to get
pushed a little further?
And can have this synergistic
activity between human learning
and then the
machine learning, so
that we can get just the
right amount of exercise
and rehabilitation
to make them better.
And we even tried
to miniaturize it.
This is somebody who's
playing a virtual goggle video
game as she is getting her
movements exercised in a way
that she was not
possible before.
So all of this was great.
And I was a professor,
and I loved teaching.
But I was getting a lot of
emails on the side from people,
people today who were injured
and really needed some help.
And they read about my
research, and said, well,
is there anything
that you can do?
And eventually, I sort of-- it
tickled me enough to the point
that I thought,
you know what, it's
great to push the
boundary of science.
But at the same
time, I would love
to be able to do something
for people today.
So I built a
foundation on the side.
It's called YokyWorks.
It's really about making
something, technology--
especially the intersection
of machine learning
and human learning--
to enable you
to become who you want to be.
So we did things
anywhere from, you know,
from a kid who wanted to
become a faster swimmer,
but had an amputation.
Is there something
that we can build?
And then another project that
I'm going to highlight today,
just as an example, is
called Project Maria.
And Maria was a seven-year-old
girl who came to YokyWorks
and said-- actually, Maria's
parents came to us-- and said,
is there anything
that Maria can do?
She has cerebral palsy.
She basically had a stroke when
she was about seven months old.
She lost almost all the
movements from her body.
She was wheelchair bound.
And there's absolutely
nothing on her body
that really could
move with her wish.
And we got together.
And then we watched
her, how she moved,
and if there's anything
we can bring out from her.
As we watched, what she had
was this on the wheelchair.
This is called a
communication board.
And all she could
do was to move just
in the general direction
of maybe four corners.
But she had no motion
that could allow
her to stop at any
of the squares.
So all she could
do was to say, yes.
I'm in pain.
I have to go to the bathroom.
That's about it.
But her parents said--
and I felt the same,
as we were watching
her-- that she
has something inside, a very,
very smart person inside.
And we wanted to enable this.
So, as the parents
and I were talking,
and the therapist was
there, Maria got bored.
I mean, any
seven-year-old would get
bored of parents
talking about something
that's pretty serious.
So she asked, in
sort of her way,
and her parents noticed
that she should probably
look at the iPhone pictures.
So her dad gave her the phone.
And as I watched
in the background,
she was swiping like this.
I was like, wait a second.
So if she was motivated enough
to want to look at something,
she can actually make
those swiping motions,
even though she is unable to
stop at a specific location.
So we said, aha!
Why don't we take
advantage of the fact
that she can make those
motions, and maybe
allow us to-- so we should
build a technology that
can adapt to her
motion over time.
And it maybe just,
understand how much
she can be pushed to learn.
And then we'll build a
technology around it.
So we went to-- a
nonprofit has no money.
So we went to Toys 'R' Us.
And we had found an
electronic drum machine.
And we said, oh, this
looks really good.
They have, like, areas
that she can go to.
But wait, this is a
pushing motion still.
She can't make
pushing precisely.
So we also bought rubber
balls, cut it in half,
and then we put them-- instead
of those little, the surface
piece, now, she's moved
to swipe, like the iPhone,
into different directions.
She was able to knock
down on different corners.
And now, this is
actually beautiful Maria.
Just, she's learning how to use
this device-- as you can see,
the drum set with the
rubber ball attached to it.
Of course, we were
shooting them.
And she was a little shy
in front of the camera.
But you will see her sort
of general swiping motion,
the kind of things
that she can do.
So she's able to
actually be told
which ones she should
go for, and then
trying to target toward those
motions, the directions.
So what I loved about
this idea was not only
that we were replacing those
communications in a much more
precise way-- she just
had to knock one of those
over with the motions
she already has.
But now, we've started
to say, you know what?
If she can get good
at those four corners,
she can actually start to
build a vocabulary around it.
What if left top and
bottom right was letter a?
What if some other combination
was letter b, and so forth.
And if we learned
it together, she
could actually learn to spell.
She could learn to form essays.
She could take SATs.
She could go to college.
And she could get her own job,
and she could live on her own.
And that just was so
exciting to be able to do.
So this is the
kind of way that we
wanted to mix the
machine learning
from the side of really
understanding her capabilities
and trying to adapt, even
build devices to accommodate
and then to make her give
the human experience.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
One of the things that
YokyWorks has taken, of course,
is something that's
not just for her,
but we wanted it to be
for a lot more people.
Devices for disabled
people, of course,
is not something that
you can mass-produce.
It's sort of a good
thing and a bad thing.
So, you know, we were hoping
that through this work,
we could even find
hundreds, maybe just
thousands of people who would
use the same technology.
And then we could work
with them to get, you know,
this enablement of these lives.
So, just to close, I
wanted to sort of really
highlight this idea of machine
learning and human learning
intersection.
And I'm really excited to
keep working this intersection
in both consumer products,
as well as for individuals.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So now, I'm happy to
introduce Gabriella Levine.
She's on the rapid
eval team at Google X.
And she travels
all over the world.
And we'll hear all about that.
[APPLAUSE]
GABRIELLA LEVINE: Thank you.
I'm Gabriella Levine.
As introduced, I work
on the rapid eval team,
part of Google X. What the rapid
eval team is tasked with doing
is coming up with new
moon-shot projects.
So this means crazy,
out-of-the-box technological
solutions to projects that
potentially could solve some
of the world's largest problems
that affect billions of people.
What we value is to work
hands-on to build things,
to dive right in, and to work
with tools that we can feel.
But we embrace failure.
And we like to fail fast.
Today, I want to
tell you a little bit
about the type of
work that I do,
and what got me here
on the rapid eval team.
I've always been really
passionate about working
outside, in nature,
and dealing with things
that were harsh conditions.
So this led me to
spend a few seasons
as a wildland firefighter,
based in Oregon.
I was on a hot-shot
crew, which meant
that we would travel
all over the US
to America's largest fires.
So we would be in the middle
of the forest, no access
to roads, food,
far from anything.
It was super-mentally
challenging and physically
demanding.
But it was one of the most
exciting jobs I ever had.
But I was around
lots of big machines
that tried to fight the fires.
And often, it was efficient.
But sometimes, it was
really not the best way
to use these big machines
that cost a lot of money,
took a lot of manpower.
So sometimes, it was even just
to show nearby towns that there
was a lot of airspace
happening, even
when a fire was too
big to get near.
It was often really
the ground crews
that made a lot of difference.
So it really got me thinking
about automated machines,
and robots, and
especially those that
dealt with the environment.
From there, I really
just started prototyping,
and wanted to build
my own robots that
could go into the environment
and potentially solve
some natural disaster issues.
So I ended up building a
lot of bio-inspired robots,
and a lot of snake
robot prototypes, which
are called Sneel.
That's a story for
a different day.
But this led me to keep
building and learn as I went,
and eventually
co-create a startup
called Protei, dealing
with a robot that
can go into the environment
and mitigate natural disasters.
This startup led me to
another radical experiment.
It was called
Unreasonable at Sea.
I was one of ten tech
startups last year
on a 4 and 1/2 month journey
around the world by ship.
So this was my home.
I was one of about 30 social
entrepreneurs on the ship.
But it was a partnership
with Semester at Sea.
So it was all of us part
of the accelerator program,
with business mentors and
about 600 university students.
It was weird.
But it was really amazing.
So we traveled together from
San Diego down to Mexico,
across the Pacific Ocean,
around Asia, India, and then
all around Africa,
up to Barcelona.
Together, we were working with
each other-- the businesses
and the students working
with the mentors,
working with people at local
communities in the ports,
just innovating
together, brainstorming.
And we were
deploying our robots.
So the startup that I
helped start and grow
is called Protei.
Protei is an open-source,
shape-shifting sailing robot,
meant to explore and
preserve the ocean.
So eventually, it's going to be
unmanned, fully sustainable, as
well as autonomous.
But it moves like a
snake through the water.
And the purpose
is so that it can
carry long and heavy material
behind it, like sensors,
or payload for
cleaning up the ocean,
like this oil-absorbent,
polypropylene tail.
But the biomorphic
body actually moves
like a snake, and curves
in the wind, presumably
increasing efficiency
during the tack.
So the idea is that,
with this flexible body,
it can increase efficiency,
have lower drag,
and decrease the
reduction of energy
as it moves through the water.
But Protei is a fully
open-source hardware project,
which means that we
document the designs,
really to enable
local communities
to take a hands-on approach to
whatever environmental disaster
they're trying to look at with
an autonomous surface vessel.
So you could take out
the central electronics.
And right now, it's
just a remote control
talking to an
arduino on board that
changes the shape
of the boat, as well
as the trim of the sail.
But you could put
a Linux computer
on, or even an Android.
You could put any sensor
you want on the boat,
to measure any type of data
that you want on the water,
or exchange the
radio for something
like an iridium satellite,
in order to-- an antenna,
to presumably have this vision
of multiple boats swarming
around the world, anywhere.
And then you could be at
home, controlling the boat
from the comfort
of your own home,
much like on a video
game interface.
Protei's being developed to
solve some of the biggest
natural disasters-- for
example, the oil spill.
It was inspired by the
BP oil spill in 2010.
And something like this might
enable all the fishermen
who ended up helping and getting
skin diseases and lung diseases
to be taken out of the picture.
So robots could
end up doing that.
It's also being developed
to map plastic trash
in the middle of the ocean,
by having an optical camera
on the front of the boat
that water streams through
so it can measure the particles
and the microplastic size
on the surface of the water.
And it's being developed to
map radioactivity on the coast,
as well as in the
water-- for example,
near Fukushima, after
the Fukushima Daiichi
nuclear meltdown.
So wherever we went on
Unreasonable at Sea,
we worked with
local communities,
seeing what their needs might
be to have an autonomous boat.
And we deployed the boat.
And we really
tried to understand
the needs and the
people, as well
as how the boat would
work in different types
of environments.
When we got to Ghana, we
learned that oil had just
been discovered eight years ago.
Now there were oil rigs
all along the coast,
as well as the
fishermen would go
and fish right along the oil.
We wanted to see,
how can Protei be
used to understand
the relationship
between the fishermen,
the fish, and the oil?
Now, at night, the
fish would gather
around the oil rigs, which
had bright lights, which
was something that
never used to happen.
Instead of just going and
interviewing and talking
to some people, we
met some friends.
We headed directly to the beach,
and got on a fishing boat.
We rode out with them, and
ended up fishing with them.
I was really sick this
day, and actually,
throwing up over the side
of the boat as I paddled.
But it really didn't matter.
It was amazing.
And I just kept paddling
as hard as I could.
When we got to
Hawaii, we learned
that every island has its
own rainbow beach, modeled
with plastic trash that
comes in from the ocean.
We worked with some
of the scientists
there to see how Protei
might be used to map plastic
trash in the middle
of the Pacific Ocean.
Now, we're continuing
efforts with these scientists
to see what Protei might be
able to do all over the world.
Finally, Protei is
engaging with a project,
working with the disaster that
happened in 2011, the Fukushima
Daiichi nuclear meltdown
after the earthquake.
This is one of the biggest
disasters of the century.
And it's going to affect
people for centuries to come.
We wanted to see if
Protei could help map
the radioactivity off
the coast of Fukushima,
as well as in the
water-- something
that I never had seen
data about before.
There's an organization called
Safecast, based in Tokyo.
And they handed out open-source
Geiger counters in 2011.
This allowed people to collect
data all over the country.
And they crowdsource-mapped
the entire country,
based on radioactivity levels.
We wanted to see, could Protei
do this, but for the water?
And all we needed was a boat to
put one of the Geiger counters
on.
So this gave us nine days to
build a boat between Hawaii
and Japan, which was very
early on in the journey.
So imagine building on a boat.
It's not very easy.
We were on the second-level
deck, way below the water line.
And it was like trying to
solder on Space Mountain roller
coaster, as it pendulums
back and forth.
Plus, we ended up hitting
one of the worst storms
that the seasoned British
captain said he's ever seen.
At one point, he got
on the loudspeaker.
And he said, "Everybody,
get to your rooms!
Things are looking grim."
So we didn't care.
As I was, like, soldering
the PCBs for Geiger counters,
the student interns
were epoxying
the outside of the boats.
And we kept working, even as
wood was flying everywhere
as the boat shook, and
electronics, and epoxy.
But we had to finish the boat
by the time we got to Japan.
So after countless
nights of not sleeping,
we finally were finishing as we
pulled into port that morning.
And this was a huge relief.
This was one of the most
beautiful sunrises I had ever
seen, as the seas
finally calmed.
So we head directly to
Safecast's headquarters.
We modified the
Geiger counters so
that we can put
them in the water,
as well as get data
from under the water.
And we head off in a car with
some of the Safecast team,
drove through the night
to Fukushima from Tokyo.
In the morning, we
finally arrived.
And it was like a
post-apocalyptic scene.
It was totally destroyed.
And the landscape was desolate.
It was a ghost town.
But we drove as
close as we could
to the last possible barrier
that had been opened up.
We were five miles
from the nuclear plant.
We put the boat in the
water with the sensors.
And we didn't know
if we'd get any data.
But it was really exciting.
As we lowered the sensors
down to the mineral
layer of the ocean
floor, we were actually
able to see trace
amounts of radioactivity.
So this was really exciting.
And Protei's continued
collaboration with Safecast,
and aims to go back
in October to continue
to map radioactivity
there, and all
over the world in the ocean.
So sometimes, when
I've been faced
with crazy problems, real-world
problems, natural disasters,
I've been forced to
think of crazy solutions
and try them out, right
there on the spot.
Sometimes, they've
been total failures.
But regardless, I've
learned a lot from it.
So just by trying,
just by diving in,
and not being afraid
to fail, that sometimes
lead to crazy, wild ideas
that-- like weird snake boats--
that might potentially solve
some of the world's biggest
challenges.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
Thank you.
So now, I'm going to
introduce somebody
else who works on Google X and
some crazy robots that deal
with harsh environmental
terrain, this time on Mars.
[APPLAUSE]
JAIME WAYDO: Hi.
My name is Jaime Waydo.
I am a systems engineer
at Google X, where
we work on self-driving cars.
But I want to talk to
you today about not
an Earth self-driving car, but
a self-driving car on Mars.
Let's start with
me in eighth grade.
And I can't believe I'm
showing you this picture.
This is over-permed hair
that was very fashionable
at the time, I promise you.
I have decided in my
life, at this point,
that I'm going to be a
professional musician.
And then I go to
a science class.
And my science teacher
is talking to us
about Mars and space.
And he's telling us
about the NASA missions,
like Viking, that happened
in the '70s, where
two Viking landers actually
landed on the surface of Mars,
and collected data,
and maybe, maybe not,
found evidence of life.
And I'm like, gosh,
that's amazing.
I'm doing that.
Now, at the time, NASA
is not going to Mars.
There are no Mars
missions on the books.
We haven't been to
Mars since the '70s.
I'm not that old.
And so, we now need
a way to get there.
But that's my dream.
That's what I'm doing.
By the time I get
to high school,
I realize that to go to Mars
and to go to NASA, what I really
need to do is work at NASA's Jet
Propulsion Laboratory, or JPL,
as we call it.
And I need to probably
be a mechanical engineer.
So that's what I decide to do.
I go to college in
mechanical engineering.
And I end up waiting tables
at Perkins Family Restaurant
and Bakery, which is
like a Denny's, maybe?
And I am waiting tables.
And a guy comes in.
And it turns out he's
just retired from JPL.
And he has just moved to
Bozeman, Montana, where
I'm working and going to school.
And he says, come over to my
house, and we'll talk about it.
So of course, I go
to a stranger's house
in the middle of
nowhere, because that
seems like a good idea.
And I get an interview
a week later.
I have an internship
a week after that,
which is pretty amazing.
And so this is the early
years at JPL for me.
The early years
were really focused
on testing and proving
out the landing systems
to get two twin
rovers, Curiosity--
or, sorry, Spirit
and Opportunity,
safely to the surface of Mars.
And I ran a huge test program.
And these are the guys
that worked for me.
You can see me-- at the time,
I had red hair-- in the back.
And then, all of
the guys helping me
pull off all of those tests.
And by the early
2000s, I had been
assigned to work
on my first child.
And this is her.
Her name is Curiosity.
She was slated to
go to Mars in 2007,
turns out we launched in 2009.
But I'm in charge of
all things mobility.
And so, what does that mean?
That means-- yeah!
[APPLAUSE]
Differential, the suspension,
the wheels-- everything
on your car that
makes your car go.
The same things are on a
Rover that make a Rover go.
They're also the same things
on a self-driving car.
And so it all kind of
ties together, right?
I'm working on this.
One of the things we
worked on is the wheel.
And that was my
team, me and a bunch
of guys who worked for me.
And so, the wheel
is really special.
When you go to Mars, it gets
down to 135 below centigrade.
And it gets up to 70 centigrade.
And so you can't go with
traditional materials.
So the wheel's actually
made out of an aluminum rim.
And that wall thickness of that
skin of that tire is 30,000ths
thick.
To put that in
perspective, that's
the thickness of
three sheets of paper.
And that's what makes
that wheel round and hold.
People continually ask me,
why did you make so thin?
Especially right now, with the
story I'm about to tell you.
And the reason is, there are
six wheels on the vehicle.
And so, every ounce of
material you put on there
is multiplied by six.
And so we're constantly--
one of our key constraints
is that we have to
make it lightweight.
Another one is that we have to
be able to climb large rocks.
This is a mobile platform that
wants to climb up a mountain.
And another thing
is that we have
to really cushion the
way the vehicle drives.
So you can see the
spoked wheels in here.
It's six titanium flexures, kind
of like a spoked bicycle wheel,
but now in three dimensions.
And that's the
design we propose.
And we start testing it.
Now, you may know,
Curiosity is pretty special.
It's a brand-new
landing system for NASA.
So we actually
have a jetpack that
flies her close to
the surface of Mars.
And then she drops down
from the jetpack, and lands
on her wheels--
which sounds so easy.
And in all of the videos
that they show about it,
it's super benign.
But imagine, you don't get
to pick your landing spot.
So there can be slopes,
and there can be rocks.
So we actually test that.
And we started out with some
of our early prototypes.
And this is high-speed video.
I promise we're not
moving that slow.
And so that wheel
is coming down,
and we're testing
to see what happens
when you land on major rocks.
We want to make sure we're
designing a wheel that works.
And so the wheel's
going to come down.
And it's going to hit this rock.
And you'll watch
the rock puncture
through the skin of the
tire, and totally deform it.
But then, it almost
all bounces back.
And all you've got are these
little cracks in the wheel.
And then we tested that.
And we drove it over a
whole bunch of terrain
to make sure that
those cracks don't
do what we call
propagate, or spread out.
And we made sure
it was good to go.
And so we tested all of that.
We also took her out into what
we call the Mars Yard at JPL,
where we simulate
the Martian terrain.
And if you know a thing
or two about mobility
systems for Mars, you
know that you really
want to design a
mobility system that
can climb one wheel diameter.
But for me and my team,
that wasn't sufficient.
So we got extra credit.
And we can climb
two wheel diameters.
We don't ever let her do
that on Mars, I promise.
But she can do it.
This is her early
prototype, just
so you get a little
bit of a story here.
Her name is Scarecrow.
And we call her
Scarecrow because she
doesn't have a brain.
It's just a little button
box we drive her with.
We also tested-- so
those were tall rocks.
Now we're testing wide rocks.
And one of the things we found
when we drove over wide rocks
is this phenomena where
the vehicle actually gets
one wheel on one
side of the rock, one
wheel on the other
side of the rock,
and then starts lifting those
rocks up off of the ground.
And those really do
damage to the wheels.
And so we thought, well, gosh.
What are we going to do?
We're getting close to launch.
This is a bad idea.
We need to fix this.
And so I said, I know.
We'll just tell the drivers,
don't drive over wide rocks.
So that's what we did.
And they don't drive
over wide rocks.
They're doing a great job.
We also test her
inside the clean room.
And so this is me
and my friend Peter.
And we're making
sure that, when we
tell the wheels to go forward,
the rover goes forward.
And when we tell her to go
backwards, she goes backwards.
And when we tell her to steer,
she steers the right way.
So a very basic test to
really build the confidence
that we built the right vehicle.
And then the extreme tests we
do on Scarecrow, to make sure
that we've done
everything right.
Then we launch her.
This is out of Cape Canaveral.
And we say goodbye.
And, gosh, this is really
like postpartum depression
for a rover momma.
And so our baby's gone.
Yeah.
Which is an exciting day.
It's like you've sent
her off to college.
But she's never coming back.
She gets to Mars.
She takes a selfie, says hi.
I'm here.
She really does.
That's her taking that.
We don't fake that, I promise.
And so everything
looks good, right?
And I go on my merry way.
I go off to Google X. And all
of a sudden, the phone rings.
And they say, Jaime, have you
seen what we're driving on?
And I look.
And this is the picture I have.
And the rocks are like nothing
we've ever seen on Mars.
We've landed on Mars
at NASA quite a bit.
And we're, in fact, fairly
good at landing on Mars.
We have never seen rocks
that look like this.
They're basically
knife-edged pyramids.
And we're driving
over a lot of them.
And I'm like, well,
how bad is it?
This is the next
picture they sent me.
And these are the
wheels-- sol 564.
So a Martian day
is called a sol.
It's 45 minutes longer
than an Earth day.
And so we're about a year, a
little more, into the mission.
We want to go for two years.
And we've got holes all over.
And they're pretty
significant, right.
That's not really
what we designed.
We did design holes
in the wheels.
Does anybody know
what the holes say?
Yeah?
JPL in Morse code, that's right.
Leaving our fingerprints all
over the surface of Mars.
See, engineers have fun, right?
So, yeah.
We basically have the equivalent
of a Martian flat tire.
And I realize that I'm in the
situation where there's not
going to be a right answer.
We are completely
over-constrained.
And so I say, well, the
first thing I would do
is I would drive backwards.
And they're like, what?
And I said, well, what we
did is we designed Curiosity
so that whatever trouble
she gets into going forward,
she's actually better
at driving in reverse.
So turn her around.
She's a robot.
She doesn't care.
Turn the camera around.
And you're good to go.
Just drive backwards.
You're at least doing
damage to different wheels.
And so they do that.
They don't really
like it, because they
don't have as good a
view of the cameras.
But she's doing great.
Then I tell them, can we
not drive on those rocks?
So we start driving
on sandier soils.
But sanding soil
isn't fun, either.
Curiosity is like a
little kid in a sandbox.
She gets in.
And she can start
throwing up sand
all over herself that
gets on the science
instruments and the cameras.
And she can actually
bury herself.
The reason we actually put
JPL in the wheels is-- well,
we wanted to put our
fingerprints on Mars.
But it's also because we
know how big the wheel is.
And we know how far apart
those asymmetric tread patterns
should be in the surface.
And so we can measure the
distance in our cameras.
We know how far
apart they should be.
We know how far apart they are.
And that difference is
how much she's slipping,
so that we make sure she's
not burying herself in,
like Spirit did.
So we do that.
But it's slow going.
And you can see here,
it's a lot of slipping,
and a lot of dust being
thrown up everywhere.
So again, the scientists
aren't super-happy
that we have to do this.
But it's better than
tearing up those wheels.
Another thing we do is we
take a lot more pictures.
She's not taking
selfies up here anymore.
She's taking selfies
of her shoes,
and making sure that we're
tracking the damage that's
happening to those wheels.
We have two twins now.
You see Scarecrow.
There's another twin, I'm not
really sure what her name is.
It was VSTB, for
Vehicle System Test Bed.
We're not always fun,
when we're engineers.
But this is the Mars Yard again.
And what we do now is we've got
orbiters that fly over Mars.
They take
high-resolution pictures
of the surface of Mars.
And then, from
that, we mock up--
with interns carrying rocks
all around-- what that terrain
is going to look like.
We test it on Earth.
And we make sure it's OK.
And then we can go on Mars.
You can see that's a
huge amount of work,
a ton of logistics, and
very time consuming.
But we do it to
make sure that she's
doing what she's supposed to.
Another thing we do, we
just don't drive as much.
So we sit here.
This is a place called the
Kimberly, because apparently it
looks like the
Kimberly in Australia.
And she's sitting there
right now, actually,
drilling and doing a lot
of really great science.
But it's a compromise.
Everything is a compromise.
The scientists want to be
at the top of that mountain.
And we're just probably
not going to get there.
And that's really
unfortunate, when
you're a mobility engineer,
and you've designed this thing
to give the scientists all
of their dreams come true.
But what I've
realized through this
is that the thing that I'm most
passionate about in engineering
is being on those
problems-- the problems that
are completely over constrained.
The ones where there's
not a right answer,
because everything
is just wrong.
And you get to be in
the center of that.
And you get to figure out how
to solve those compromises.
Which constraints are wrong?
Push back.
Which ones are really important,
and you have to listen to?
And how do you tune that answer
to really optimize across
no good answer?
And that's the part that
I just totally love,
because you get to be creative.
And you get to really put your
fingerprints on the design.
And so this is us, leaving our
fingerprints on the surface.
And I encourage you, when
you're in those moments,
to realize that
that answer is going
to be uniquely yours, because
it's you, and no one else,
solving it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
I get to-- I have to
tell you a little story.
When I was getting
ready to go to Google X,
I Googled Google X to try
to figure out what it was,
because it was
pretty top secret.
And I came across a video with
our next speaker, Megan Smith.
And I was blown away.
And I told my husband, I'm
like, I cannot wait to meet this
woman.
And every day I come home
from work at Google X,
and he's like, have you
met Megan Smith yet?
I'm like, no.
And he calls her my work crush.
I haven't told her
that until right now.
And so I am very excited.
It is on my bucket
list of things to do.
I get to introduce
the Megan Smith.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
MEGAN SMITH: Hello.
That was incredible.
It's clear to me that hardware
is definitely the new black.
You know, we wanted to
focus on robotics, because
for this Women
Techmaker session,
the second one that we've had
in our new tradition at I/O.
Because there's just
extraordinary things happening
in robotics right now.
It's really entering
the mainstream
in so many ways, and so
many parts of our lives.
And there's really
extraordinary women
who are part of those teams.
And so we wanted to
bring it, like we
do with Women Techmakers.
We want to talk about and
show you extraordinary women.
Also, the other
thing about robotics
is that, for whatever reason,
because of media bias,
are the things, when
we think of robotics
and who is making them, we
do think about boys and men.
And so, that kind of brings
me to Women Techmakers.
And I just wanted
to say a little bit
about Women Techmakers and this
idea of debugging inclusion.
So this is a photo from 2012.
And what we thought
of at that time--
Google I/O was only
in the single digits
of percentages of women.
I think there were about 300
women in Google I/O of 2012.
And so we decided that
the night before, we
would have a
gathering, so people
would have some
friends in the hallway
and not feel like
such a minority.
And so this is an
image from then.
And I just wanted to show
you an image from, whatever,
two nights ago, or last night--
the one of the many dinners.
We have more than 1,000
women here at I/O.
And we had 800 women out
to dinner in a gathering.
Very exciting.
The other thing that happened
in 2012 was, you know,
one of things that's true about
diversity at work, none of us
created any of the biases
that are happening to us.
We inherited the
world that we live in.
And so it's not that we
should feel guilty about them.
What we should do is, as
we wake up and see them,
you know, many of them
are very unconscious.
As we wake up and see them, we
should do things about them.
And so one of things
we thought in 2012,
since we really noticed
just how invisible
the women, the
technical women, are.
And so, one of the
things we've started
to do with Women
Techmakers is we
began to make a video series.
And so we had
videos from Mexico,
from London, from
Silicon Valley,
from New York, all around the
world, of just interviewing
technical women and get
them in front of you.
We also started to do things
around Google I/O again.
So for 2013, we really
worked hard to make
sure we put extraordinary
women onto the main stage
at the key note.
This is Johanna.
And then we had our first
Women Techmakers session,
which was called "Seven
Techmakers and a Microphone."
And one of my favorite talks
at that was Kathy Kleiman.
I don't know if
people were there.
But she talked about a
70-year-old lost history
story of the first
programmers in America.
Six women, who
during World War II,
were Rosie the Mathematician.
And they were handed the
wiring diagrams of the ENIAC.
And they had been calculating
ballistic trajectories, which
was a differential equation
that took a good, you know,
week long to do.
And they said,
could you do this,
because it'd be a great demo.
And they went in and
wrote the first sort
routines and made those happen.
That movie has now been
made that Kathy introduced
that was going to be there.
And it's going to-- it's already
on the film festival tour.
And we're going to start
to do some film festivals.
We're doing one at
Hopper, with the Maker
series, which is great.
The next thing that
happened was Natalie joined.
And she started to really
drive us to do things.
And this is an idea that we had
for International Women's Day.
During that month of March,
everybody's celebrating women.
And we thought we could engage
the Google Developer Groups.
And many of the leaders are
here in the room, so thank you.
So this is the team in Nigeria.
And, in fact, this is
the map that shows you.
Over 11,000 technical
women met around the world,
during the month of March.
Met each other, began
to build community,
began to know about resources,
and began to drive visibility.
And so we had, I think,
52 different countries,
and over 125 events.
So thank you to the GDPs and
folks who made this happen.
It's so important.
So this is what we saw.
And now we're also starting
to expand our resources.
And one of things that
happened this year was many
of these partners on
screen-- Girl Develop It,
Women Who Code, and others,
Hackbright Academy--
helped us find a lot of
the women that are here,
the women who we should
have been inviting.
And so we worked
with many of them.
And then I also
wanted to let you
know that we've partnered
with Code School.
So the Women
Techmakers are going
to be offering three
months of free access
for women who want to
come in and hone skills,
intermediate and beginner level.
So I guess my ask to all of
you is, as Women Techmakers,
now we've got a platform.
So let's keep pushing.
Let's all work on
this visibility.
building community.
I think that what's cool and
amazing about the tech industry
is we're really
mission-driven people.
And we really believe that
we can make the changes.
We work on all these
extraordinary products.
And so, even though, like
all the other industries,
we have these issues with
bias, and with trouble,
and with things that
have gone before,
we are one of the
most innovative groups
on the planet.
And so I think we actually
have the possibility
to move the fastest
to change all of this,
and to really include
the people that we need
in the innovation in this world.
So thank you for being
here, and for hearing
these incredible women,
and for all the work
that everybody does.
It's definitely
only going to work
if we have parallel
processing everywhere,
parallel innovation.
One of the things I
love about the fact
that our L team-- Larry's team,
and the executives at Google--
set a goal for us to be--
could we be the best company
for women and
underrepresented minorities?
Could we figure
out how to do that?
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
And--
--and you see us doing
this innovative work,
really piloting
things, trying things.
Some of them will work.
Some won't.
We released our
numbers to try to get
our mind around the challenges.
But really, what it really did
by setting that goal, to me,
was it opened up
the innovation space
to all of us that wonder,
what does that mean?
How would I measure that?
How can I actually
make an impact?
And so that's what
we're all up to.
And we hope you'll
join us, and set
that goal for our
whole industry.
So thank you for being here.
And I think we're going
to go to Q&A, right?
OK, so come on up.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
So all of our speakers
are going to come up.
And also Natalie
Villalobos, who runs Women
Techmakers and been driving
this, and [INAUDIBLE],
together with Stephanie
Liu, who's here,
and some of the other folks.
So I think we have, like,
five minutes for some couple
questions.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Yeah, about five minutes.
I actually have a
question to Jaimie.
So why do you call it a her?
JAIME WAYDO: Thank you.
I forgot to tell you that.
So everybody at JPL calls our
rovers by the female pronoun
she and her.
Some will tell you that it's
after the Navy tradition, where
they name their
ships after females,
because they're
difficult to control.
MEGAN SMITH: Whew!
[LAUGHTER]
JAIME WAYDO: I
think it's actually
because they're amazing,
beautiful creations.
And we should celebrate that.
So that's why I her her.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yay!
[APPLAUSE]
But yeah, so we have some
mics up at the front.
We already have one
nice gentleman here.
What's your question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
It's not as much a question,
but-- I'm from Toronto, Canada.
And my wife actually
runs two organizations
called Ladies Learning Code
and Kids Learning Code.
I don't know if you've had a
chance to take a look at them.
But if you haven't, I strongly
recommend you take a look.
It's exactly what
you guys are doing.
And I'm sure they'd love to
participate in whenever you do.
MEGAN SMITH: Where's your wife?
AUDIENCE: She is back in
Toronto, unfortunately.
She's running some
workshops, and preparing
for the entire summer
of camp, and what not.
MEGAN SMITH: Nice.
So Ladies-- say it again?
AUDIENCE: Ladies Learning Code--
MEGAN SMITH: Ladies
Learning Code.
AUDIENCE: --and
Kids Learning Code.
MEGAN SMITH: And
AUDIENCE: Girls Learning
Code as well, sorry.
MEGAN SMITH: OK, and
Girls Learning Code.
So we will add those into--
we have the Women Techmakers
site, which Natalie's got
all kinds of resources.
Every time you want to
tell us about stuff,
we'll add them there.
And also, last week, we launched
the Made With Code high-school
girl outreach program,
which is the things you love
are made with code.
For whatever reason,
they don't know that.
And we need to tell them.
So we'll add the
girls-related stuff there.
AUDIENCE: We saw that, and
thought it was really amazing.
She's really excited to
use some of that stuff.
And thanks, yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah,
thanks for being here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: This question
is for Gabriella.
When she was taking the
measurements for the Fukushima
disaster along the coast
and measuring its impact
in the coastal Pacific,
what was the outcome,
or what is the
conclusion to that?
Is that something that we could,
at this moment, be fearful
of all the fish?
Does it jeopardize
our food chain?
Seafood chain?
GABRIELLA LEVINE: So that
was my question as well.
What's going on under water?
Because people are
eating the seafood.
People are fishing.
And it's being distributed.
We just got a very
little amount of data.
And it was with a
very rough sensor.
So we're trying to
continue that effort.
And Protei's trying to
take to get more partners
to get more data faster.
At the moment, yeah, there's
not all that much data about it.
But there are other
resources to look
at that I could also
talk to you about after.
MEGAN SMITH: We ran a
session, "Solve for X,"
solveforx.com session,
which is one of the passion
projects at Google X.
And there's a guy, Lou,
who's here, who's doing
really interesting
crowd-source measure
monitoring across China.
The Ali Baba team actually
went home from vacation
doing crowd source--
it's called Danger Map.
Look for that video.
But this idea that Gabriella
and others are onto,
and your point which actually
drew from your insight
from firefighting, that
sometimes the big, meta stuff
isn't as good as small pieces
on the ground and lots of datas.
And so using robots in this
form is what she's advocating,
I think.
And we need to get
out, as developers,
and innovate more of that,
and do more measurement,
so that we can exactly
have the answers.
Not only for this
Chinese project in China,
or projects around the world,
and to engage youth into them,
but also specifically
for oceans.
AUDIENCE: Well, living
in the Bay Area,
you know, this is a
real major concern.
Because already,
there are some areas
that, you know, they have
signs posted, do not fish here.
GABRIELLA LEVINE: Right.
AUDIENCE: And that's kind
of in the back of my mind.
Thank you.
MEGAN SMITH: Thank you.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Daphne Larose.
And hearing all of your stories
was-- as a fellow engineer,
it's, like, really
inspiring and wonderful.
And as someone who has
made it my own mission
to bring visibility not
just to women in tech,
but women of color
in tech, I think
it's just awesome to hear
about what you guys have done.
One of the questions I've
often had for myself,
and that I hear a lot
from other engineers,
is how do you find your niche?
So each of you
kind of have, like,
an area that you just
seem to fall into.
But, like, how did
you discover that?
And where did you really
discover your passion?
JAIME WAYDO: I'll tell you
how I discovered my passion.
I had it at JPL.
I was sending stuff to Mars.
And I was super-stoked about it.
And when you're doing things
that you're passionate about,
you rock at it.
And that's pretty fun.
Then I left.
And I went into medical
for a while, and hated it.
Lost my passion.
Couldn't figure out what it was.
And it was actually
through Natalie
calling me to do this
talk that I figured out
what I love again.
And it's solving those
gnarly, crazy problems.
So thank you to Women
Tech, because you
made me find my
passion again, so.
MEGAN SMITH: Other questions--
[APPLAUSE]
--other passion stories?
Passions?
GABRIELLA LEVINE: I think
mine's a little similar.
It was-- or, some
similar aspects.
I found a community that I
really love to work with,
and the tools that I
really loved working with.
From there, it came easy.
But I did have a very diverse
background, and a wide range
of things that I've done,
both very technical as well
as creative.
So it was trying
a lot of things.
Really, never saying no.
And then, getting excited
about the tools and the people
that I work with.
And I was lucky to
find that, because I
got very focused, and--
but also very unfocused,
answering big questions.
And so, a combination
of all of that.
MEGAN SMITH: Awesome.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Yeah,
I think I would
say my passion has been
always around having impact.
And that's what made me go
into technology, because I felt
it was a creative
venue to be, and also
have a huge impact on the world.
So that's been kind of my
[INAUDIBLE] to go where I go.
YOKY MATSUOKA: I'll
make sure it short.
But, you know, for me,
it's don't think too hard.
It's a big one.
AUDIENCE: As engineers, that's
all we do is think too hard.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Yeah, I
think it's really key.
Just don't think too hard.
Just get into something
that you love.
And then that might lead
you to the next passion.
And don't worry about
your life story.
It's totally OK to have
multiple chapters, you know.
I think that's
really what I think.
MEGAN SMITH: So
you have to answer.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
I also-- I'm going
to-- I don't know if Pavni
said her name when she got up.
But this is Pavni Diwajni.
She's a VP of
engineering at Google.
I just want to make
sure everyone knew that.
MEGAN SMITH: She's amazing.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
She's amazing.
MEGAN SMITH: She does so
many different things.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And then in
terms of me finding my passion,
I think that-- so I
actually know Pavni,
because we built
Google+ together.
Obviously, I'm not a VP.
But I really looked up to
her, when I was first starting
on Google+ as a
community manager.
And I think for me,
I started noticing
that I loved nourishing
large groups of people.
I loved hearing stories,
and helping people,
and assisting them
with particular asks.
But it was really about kind
of solving for a larger group.
And so I think for me, I started
to see an opportunity of,
how can I actually help
foster social movement?
And with everything that's
going on in our industry,
I think I just needed to
add more fuel to that.
And I wanted to dedicate
my life to that.
MEGAN SMITH: I got
to take acoustics
from Professor Bose--
like Bose speakers.
And he used to tell us, you
guys are high performers.
You have to find your passion.
If you find your passion,
you can be unstoppable.
He said it's the number
one thing you need to do.
And so, I think it's a
really important question
for people to ask themselves.
And I think also for women, to
like also be present-- like,
get out and speak and
talk about your passions.
Because you have amazing
things to talk about, too.
For myself, I was
lucky because I
got to do science fair as a kid.
And I like-- I work on a
million different things.
I'm very ADD.
So I-- but they tend
to have a theme.
One is, I really like
to work on things
that help people
with their lives.
And I like to work
on things that
reduce our impact on the planet.
And almost everything
kind of themes
around that inclusion,
those kinds of themes.
And I think, I also tend
to not be the founder.
I've done that before.
But I tend to have a
really good eye for people
who have great ideas, especially
in the early, earliest stages,
and figure out how to help them.
Reid Hoffman calls it
the smart generalists
who work with the founders.
So I tend to come up underneath
people and help them.
And I think that
in Silicon Valley,
we always focus on the founder,
when really-- Redina Dugan, who
was, I think, in this
room earlier today,
who ran DARPA, she said, there's
a new thing the basketball
teams are doing,
studying hustle.
So who's on the court with
Michael Jordan when he's really
performing?
And so there's people around
who can do that stuff.
And I like to do
that kind of work.
And I think that those
are very valid jobs.
And they really
move stuff forward.
Because people have
extraordinary ideas.
If you can amplify them,
major things can happen.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And
to add to that, and then
actually, we're going
to have end Q&A.
But we'll be over here,
and available to answer
more questions.
So Megan actually taught me
a really important thing,
which was the term yes and.
I never took improv theater
classes when I was younger.
And so, surround
yourself with people
that say "yes and" to
you, more than "yes but."
Thank you so much
for joining us.
[APPLAUSE]